and the Oscar goes
to Kenneth
Grana I'm many standing here because of
the incredible support of Dame Donna
Langley Brian Roberts Peter Kowski
fearless leader of Focus Features Jason
cassid in their amazing team at Northern
Ireland screen our brilliant UK cting
crew led by Tamar Thomas Laura Beric and
Becca kovic uh this uh story is the
search for joy and hope in the face of
violence and loss we lost some people
along the way Johnny sessions Jim dor
and Leia Newman we miss them we love
them we will never forget them and we
will never forget all of those lost in
the heartbreaking heartwarming human
story of that amazing city of Belfast on
the fabulous island of Ireland this
means a lot thank you so much thank you